devant ce laboratoire d'analysés
médicales c'est le branle bas de combat
il s'agit d'effectuer des tests de
dépistage du coc vide 19
les prélèvements sont réalisés sans que
les patients n'aient à quitter leur
véhicule
les médecins viennent directement à eux
de l'autre côté de la portière l'intérêt
de faire en braille c'est déjà on prend
pas de risques nous on est quand même
protégé par la voiture et puis surtout
on fait pas rentrer les gens qui sont
possiblement positif dans le labo donc
les personnes qui ont besoin de se faire
faire une prise de temps elles peuvent
continuer à venir tranquille et le
personnel pareille ne prend pas de
risque le prélèvement est effectué grâce
à un écouvillon sorte de long coton tige
glisser au fond du narines pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce test
les patients doivent être munis d'une
ordonnance de leur médecin
car le prélèvement est proposé
uniquement aux personnes présentant des
symptômes
elles doivent ensuite prendre
rendez-vous avec le laboratoire d
analyse aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de
test on en reçoit cette semaine on en
reçoit normalement en quantité
suffisante mais aujourd'hui le dépistage
c'est pas un dépistage de masse faire un
dépistage uniquement des gens qui sont
symptomatiques et soie qui sont à risque
de formes graves soient des
professionnels de santé essentiellement
en vivant parce qu'après il ya les
patients hospitalisés bien sûr mais là
en ville on a essentiellement ces deux
catégories de personnes
une femme enceinte a justement pris
rendez vous pour se faire tester des
symptômes du kobe 19 ont alerté son
médecin ouais alors j'ai beaucoup de
tout et j'ai eu de la fièvre la semaine
dernière et je suis enceinte de sept
mois
elle fait partie de la soixantaine de
personnes environ qui seront testés ce
jour là devant le laboratoire
pas très agréable mais ça reste
supportable après le prélèvement
les résultats sont transmis par courrier
électronique généralement le jour même
une réponse rapide grâce à ces driving
médicaux qui sont encore peu nombreux en
france